laughs some breaking news from Syria
where Russia and Turkey of just
announced a ceasefire in Eid Lib the
country's last rebel held stronghold
that's the latest from our correspondent
jamal al who's in the turkish capital
ankara so tell us more about the details
of this announcement well Lauren as we
know Russia and Turkey are the two of
the three main guarantors of the
de-escalation process if we can call it
that that's been going on for a couple
of years now and attempt by regional
countries to try and bring a reduction
in the fighting after they admitted
obviously that it was difficult to bring
a total and through that and it Lib was
as you mentioned the last remaining
stronghold of the Opposition however
despite previous agreements and these
guarantors reaching some sort of a deal
to stop the violence in the constant
bombardment in it lived the past several
months have seen an escalation of
attacks both by the army of the Bashar
al-assad regime as well as by the
Russians themselves and that's led to
hundreds of thousands of civilians
essentially fleeing it lived 300,000 in
the month of December alone and most of
them of those 700,000 over the past say
seven to eight months been heading
towards Turkey which was been an added
burden obviously through the millions
that are here today so Turkey has said
for a long time that this has to stop
that there needs to be an end to the
violence there needs to be some sort of
a deal we're not quite sure exactly what
has changed things now possibly the
Turks being able to convince the
Russians who are considered to be at
least on good terms with them that there
is a need to find a solution to this but
this also comes on the eve of a visit by
the US represents Syria James Jeffries
to Turkey
so maybe is this part of something
bigger we're not quite sure but
definitely in and of itself it is very
significant and tell us a little bit
about the situation on the ground I mean
who would police or enforce any kind of
ceasefire well that's a good question I
mean there are armed rebel groups there
that for the large part fall under the
influence let's say of Turkey in terms
of the regime of Bashar al-assad as well
as
they're proxies they're ultimately they
do abide by whatever a Moscow tells them
in fact it was only a few days ago that
the Russia that the Syrian President
himself was essentially summoned to meet
the Russian president in a Russian
military base in Syria so Vladimir Putin
went to Syria and rather than meeting
Assad in the presidency I said went to
see him in a military base there which
some pundits would say reflects just the
significance or at least how the
dynamics of that relationship works so
in terms of who would police it really
that's why you have those guarantors
obviously there are certain groups that
would maybe fall out of that sphere of
influence but for large parts of the
most significant firepower let's say is
under the direct or indirect command of
both Turkey and Russia and obviously by
extension Iran as well jimana Shia thank
you very much